- So my name is Julia Istomina.
I am the Associate Director
of the Graduate Writing Lab
at Yale Poorvu Center for
Teaching and Learning.
I also administer the Poorvu Center
Public Communication Certificate program
for Graduate School Arts
and Sciences students
who compete in a Three
Minute Thesis competition.
So we're really excited to
offer this to those people
who are competing in the 3MT
and to anyone doing online presentations,
which is literally everyone right now.
I'll also add before I do the introduction
of our wonderful speaker and expert,
that they were training
us to do interviews
by Skype seven years ago.
This topic was always relevant.
I think that online
workshops and presentations
and interviews are not gonna go away.
So I think that these are
great resources to put
in your back pocket,
whether you're doing the 3MT
or some kind of really
awesome presentation
of your research,
or if you're doing more
kind of mundane job
or get things and other conferences.
So a very special person is
with us today, Guy Ortoleva.
I'm going to make his introductions.
Before I do, please make
sure that your mic is muted
and that your picture is off.
In that way, your image will
not appear in the recording.
For questions, what we're gonna do
is we're gonna have like a 15
minute Q and A at one o'clock
or a little bit before.
So if you have a question
that you'd like to ask of Guy,
please chat it and I will
keep track of them, okay?
So I will call on your first name
during the Q and A session.
So Guy Ortoleva, on behalf
of the Yale Broadcast Studio,
is going to help you
improve your presentations
with a tool kit of communication
and technical tips.
Guy and his team, I'll say right now,
they're all at the forefront
of all of the communications
that happen at the university.
So they're there front
and center for graduation,
for matriculation, for all
the ceremony, they capture it.
They share so many things publicly
and within the universities.
So these are the professionals,
they're the professionals you go to
for really quality works.
So I'm just really grateful for Guy's time
and the work that he's put
into this presentation.
To let you know a little
bit more about him.
Guy has worked in the Broadcast
Studio for several years
and both records and does video editing.
Before that, he worked
on many television shows,
like "Inside Edition" "and Hard Copy",
documentaries, commercials
and corporate training videos.
He has a JD, but more importantly,
he has 30 years of experience
in communicating with video.
So I'm gonna mute myself
and give the mic over to Guy, as it were.
So thank you so much
and welcome everybody.
- Hello, thank you for attending.
Just remember, you can put
your questions in the chat.
I did have quite a few
years working in television,
but for the past two years
at Yale, since COVID,
much of my time is
looking at Zoom recordings
from all around the world
and all the guest lecturers,
and then editing them and
trying to put them on YouTube
and wherever they're going to go.
I've seen a lot.
So hopefully, today I can show
you how to improve your image
on Zoom.
And then specifically,
we'll talk about the 3MT,
types of recordings.
When asked why the show, "60 Minutes",
was so successful for so many years,
executive producer, Don Hewitt
said, "tell me a story."
And that's pretty much it.
The success of that show has
been that every Sunday night,
they tell you a story.
That's what you're doing
when you're doing your 3MT
or anytime you're really
doing a presentation on Zoom.
You have to have a beginning,
you have to have a middle and an end.
After we've gotten MTV in the '80s,
everything happens a lot faster.
I think it's very important
for you to get the attention
of your audience in the first 15 seconds,
give them a reason
to really continue
paying attention to you.
And then at the end,
you wanna wrap it up
with some real impact.
In the middle, you're
providing all of the content.
Again, you wanna hold
people's attention throughout.
You have to be dynamic.
I found what was helpful in
planning for any presentation
that I do, that I have a
one sentence objective.
Can I sum up what I
want the takeaway to be?
What I want people to
leave with in one sentence.
And then as I prepare my material,
I hold it up to that one sentence.
Nice, is this a need to
know or a nice to know?
One of the things to keep in
mind when you're presenting
on camera and/or if you have slides,
or however you're presenting it,
people can assimilate
one thing or another.
They can't assimilate your sound
and a slide at the same time.
The balance is gonna tip
one way or the other.
So you've got something
really compelling to say,
you don't want the
slide to be distracting.
If the slide has the information
that you really need to be
showing, well, keep in mind
that people are gonna
be looking at the slide
and your voice is gonna be
kind of in the background.
What people are seeing
of you has to be useful.
Be careful of your background material,
be careful of your clothing.
We'll talk about clothing later.
But everything that's in
the frame has to be useful
and not detract from you.
So framing, lighting and audio
is how you successfully tell a story.
That's what we're going to cover today.
Proper framing really is, for example,
I'm in a fairly balanced view.
You can see me pretty well.
I have a little bit of headroom.
Background is totally
in the falling in a way,
you don't really notice it.
The lighting's pretty good.
You can see my eyes.
The audio quality is pretty good.
People, you can understand
what I'm saying.
The framing, the lighting and
the audio is really important.
Everything else is nice,
but if you fail any of those
above, you're in trouble.
Again, we're gonna discuss
the three minute thesis
specific things a little bit later on.
This fellow, Jeff Carlson,
kindly did a number of images.
This is what I see with so
many different Zoom meetings.
You have a variety of different images.
The first one is that not enough
headroom or the up to nose.
This is the same thing
with opening your laptop.
We're looking up at you,
but you're cutting the
top of your head off.
You wanna avoid looking up so much.
You're seeing the ceiling
and all that other stuff.
Second image, too much back light.
That's where you have a window
or a bright light source behind you.
As we'll talk about later,
the camera averages the amount of light.
So if you've got a lot of
bright light behind you,
your face is going to be dark.
Or worse, if you have like a window
and you start moving your head one way,
the camera will open up,
you get that almost pulsing
lighting look of the camera
will open up the iris and
then close it down quickly.
A plain white background is not so great.
It kinda looks like a mugshot,
which you don't wanna really do.
And then when you have too much headroom,
this is the other example
I use with Julia there.
Too much headroom is not so good.
You've all seen the movie, "Alien".
You've probably seen lots of scary movies.
When the music starts playing
and you just know something
bad is gonna happen,
in "Alien", the monster
comes down from above.
Well, the reason you know that
is because they've added
a little extra room
in the direction of when the
bad thing is about to happen.
So I've always said that when
you have too much headroom,
that's because there's gonna
be a monster descending
upon you.
So be careful with extra headroom.
Busy background.
There's lots of kind of busy backgrounds.
One of the ones that I see
a lot of are bookcases.
What happens, you've got a busy background
and after a while, your voice drones on
and people are really reading
the spines of the titles
in the books behind you.
They wanna see what you're reading.
They're not listening to you anymore.
So when you have a busy background,
keep in mind that is
going to be distracting.
What's the main topic?
You.
You wanna avoid distracting people.
Of course, in the bottom
right is the good balance
that we were looking for.
Before I go on to any kind of
a Zoom meeting, any of them,
I open up my Zoom Preferences
and I take a look at what I look like
and make sure that I have my
background is relatively nice.
Make sure my camera's on HD.
And then I also go to the audio
and make sure that I've got
a reasonably good audio.
The green bar, when you do a test audio,
should go about halfway to
three quarters of the way
to the right.
That's gonna give you
really pretty good sound.
I do this before anytime I go on
and I encourage you to do the same thing,
because you wanna see what you look like
and you wanna also make sure
that your audio is good.
So do this before each meeting.
What people will see.
There's a rule of thumb in video editing,
in any kind of thing with camera,
but it's built-in to our
DNA that the first thing
that people will be looking
for when they look at a frame
are other people's eyes.
It's just natural.
The next thing they'll look for is motion.
If there's anything motion in the frame.
And then after they've
satisfied themselves
with the eyes and any motion,
they're gonna start looking
around for the brightest light.
And then finally, details.
But I'll go back to the eyes.
I remember years ago, my
son had a lizard, (chuckles)
little chameleon, cute little thing.
But anytime you walk by the
room or walked in the room
or was anywhere around him, he
looked you right in the eyes.
All animals, all creatures,
all people will first look into your eyes.
That's important because
you gotta make sure
that your eyes are well-enough lit
and that they're large enough in the frame
that people are gonna see them.
Otherwise, they're
gonna be looking around.
The next thing is also your body language.
People tend to gesture
your hand out like that,
which is great.
If you're dynamic enough
speaker, a lot of times,
people will be going like this
and you'll be carrying people's attention.
But your body language has to be useful.
This doesn't help.
You're putting up a barrier.
But your body language
is an important part
and as well as how you look.
We'll cover clothing later.
But it's your visual presentation
of what you look like
on camera that says a lot.
Also, are you going to be
in the frame with the slide?
I know with the 3MT, you're using Panopto.
So you're gonna be side along side
to the left side of the slide.
In Zoom, a lot of times,
if you've got slides,
you're gonna be the
upper right hand corner.
So you've gotta anticipate
how that will look.
The best thing is to have frame
yourself up with a closeup
or what we call a medium
closeup, not your entire body,
because again, the eyes,
which is what people are
gonna be looking for,
you want them to be seen.
And then whatever slides you have,
well, they've gotta be telling a story
and they should amplify what
it is that you're saying,
because remember, it's your spoken word
and how you make your presentation
that really carries the day.
The slide is just amplifying
it or reinforcing you.
Speaking of slides, you gotta
make sure that any images
or video clips, or anything you have,
have been cleared with copyright.
You can easily get stuff
from Wikimedia comments
and other places, or
you can ask permission.
The best thing to do is
get these things clear,
because your video, your
presentation may end up on YouTube.
If it does, they'll pick it off
if you're borrowing somebody's
material without permission.
When you're speaking to an audience,
you gotta be on the same level.
I mean, you don't like it
when you have to look up at somebody.
Just opening your laptop
and starting to talk
doesn't cut it anymore.
You really have to put yourself
at the same level as the camera.
You should be lit twice as
bright as your background,
and that will create a
separation from your background.
So you're gonna have to probably
use some kind of lights,
either daylight coming in,
or maybe a light on
the table or something.
That light should be near the lens.
So it's not casting big shadows,
but it's not blinding you either.
If you're lost in the
framing, in other words,
if you've chosen to show all
of your body or most of it
rather than a medium closeup or a closeup,
it's gonna take away from your story.
I'm here to tell you.
Especially if they put
you up in the corner
or along the side, when
you're showing some slides,
you're gonna be lost in the frame.
And audio.
You gotta do the audio well enough,
so that people really understand you.
You can get headsets,
you can use your earbuds,
or best of all, use some kind
of a cardioid microphone,
something that's directional.
The microphone should be no more than two
or three feet away.
I always say an iPhone sounds great
as long as you have it close enough.
Choosing a background can be as simple
as opening up your laptop,
getting up your Zoom
image so you see yourself
and then walk around to
different places in your house.
Find a good background.
Something that has some nice, soft light
or available light coming in
so it's lighting your face,
has a pleasing background.
But move around, find the best place.
You might find two or three places.
I know my wife unfortunately
took the best place,
she does telemedicine.
So I found myself down in the
basement doing my Zoom events.
But find yourself with a good background.
Windows can hurt you if
you've got them behind you.
You wanna avoid large flat surfaces,
that will start reflecting the sound,
more of a cluttered room,
at least on the side
so we don't see it, can help
break up some of that sound.
Two most common errors in camera work.
The low angle shot.
One of my colleagues is along here
in the upper left-hand corner image.
You see, his eyeline is above the camera.
This happens typically,
people open up their laptop,
bring themselves on a Zoom
meeting and start talking.
So you're kind of looking up their nose.
And then you've got too much headroom.
So the headroom, you gotta
just tilt to monitor down.
And then, of course, the bottom right,
we have an example of proper headroom.
Back to framing.
We do in television something
called rule of sixes.
We divided image up with
six lines and six areas.
This image of me (laughs)
kinda shows the way
you wanna balance yourself out in a frame,
if you're looking straight forward.
You have a little bit of
headroom, not too much underneath.
This is what's called a medium closeup,
and that's probably your best bet.
Your eyes are gonna be visible enough.
I have one of these backgrounds,
'cause again, I'm downstairs
and I don't wanna show what's behind me,
so I use one of these virtual backgrounds.
But what I do is throw it
out of focus a little bit.
So put it in Photoshop, soften it up.
In that way, it's not distracting
or at least hopefully not
distracting from the speaker.
Now the alternative
framing is, as mentioned,
if you've got slides,
the person's gonna be in
the upper right-hand corner.
That shows me, I'm
probably blocking Julia.
But if I'm looking at one side
and I'm looking over here,
I'm looking out of frame.
So you wanna be looking in
the direction of your slides,
because if you're looking in
the direction of the slides,
if somebody's looking at your eyes,
their eyes are gonna
be led back into frame
where the slides are and
paying attention to the slides.
But if you're looking out of
frame, well, what happens?
People look at your eyes and they're lost.
They're not looking anywhere.
So keep in mind, when you're
doing a long presentation,
you may wanna have a script there.
You could put it in the
upper part of your frame,
but just make sure you
put it in the proper side,
so that you're not inadvertently
looking out a frame.
Remember the eyes are the key.
People are gonna look in your eyes.
Again, when you're in a small frame
in the upper right hand
corner of a Zoom image,
or even on the 3MTs, when
you're off to the side,
you're a smaller picture out of necessity.
So you wanna have that medium closeup shot
so that we can see you,
'cause your face is
what's really important.
But avoid drawing attention
away from the subject matter,
which is you and/or your slides.
So how does a camera see?
Well it sees like we do, it has an iris.
So in this image, when you
have a little bright light,
you squint a little bit,
or your iris will open up
to bring in more light.
A camera is pretty much the same,
only it's not quite the same.
It's not adjustable infinitely.
It adjusts to the limit of its technology,
but it has something called auto-iris.
It averages the amount of light.
So in a situation where you
have bright light behind you,
the camera is going to
average the amount of light
and it's going to close its iris down,
because it thinks it's
got plenty of light,
but what happens is now you're darker.
When technology averages,
it's not so good.
So for example, if your head is in an oven
and your feet are in the
freezer, a computer might say,
on average, that person
is quite comfortable.
So averaging in technology
isn't always your best friend.
It also happens when you have color.
One of the questions that
people will ask me sometimes
when they've seen themselves
on a Zoom is, why am I orange?
Why am I orange?
Well, it happens because
the camera is averaging,
not just the amount of light
but it's looking at the kind
of light or the color of light.
So in other words, if you have daylight,
or in the surface, a lot of white walls
with having daylight reflecting off of it,
the camera thinks that,
boom, this is more outside.
So it's going to adjust itself
to one end of the color spectrum.
If you have an incandescent
light on your desk,
your face is gonna be orange.
Quick simple solution for this
is to buy some daylight bulbs
to put in your lamp.
What about this color difference?
If you remember the old
electromagnetic spectrum
from back in your science class days,
the visible spectrum is from the low end,
which is the reds all
the way up to your blues.
So a candle light is at the one end
of low end of the
spectrum, it's very warm.
Your incandescent bulbs
that most people have
in their houses are in the
low end of the spectrum.
We measure color temperature
in kelvins, or K, we call it.
So for example, your
typical bulb that you have
in your house, your soft white
bulb is around 2,600 kelvin,
2,600K, we call it.
Daylight, on the other hand,
is probably around 56K.
A screaming blue sky
could be maybe 10,000K.
So it's way up in the
blue end of the spectrum.
So if let's say, you have a situation
where you've got some nice
soft daylight coming in,
but you also have a lamp on
helping to illuminate your face,
you wanna make sure that
the two color temperatures
are not fighting one another.
So if the camera looks at
the light and averages it
and it says, gee, we're at
the blue end of the spectrum
and you put some orange
light on your face,
you're gonna look orange,
your background is gonna look fine.
So again, that's where the
daylight bulb as an option
for your light fixtures will come in.
The other opposite end happens too.
There have been a few times
that I turn on my camera
and I'm blue.
Why?
Because I overcompensated
and I had a blue shirt on.
So sometimes, the cameras will
pick up on your clothing too
and say, oh gee, we're outdoors.
So again, take a look at yourself.
But the typical situation that comes in
that becomes a problem
is when the camera sees a lot of daylight,
just for one end of the
spectrum, the blue end,
and then you have an incandescent bulb
and now you look a little orange.
So you wanna compensate
that with the daylight bulb.
Natural light versus artificial light.
If in the upper left hand corner,
wouldn't be nice that
all our Zoom meetings
could have nice soft light
coming in through big windows,
that person looks great, but
we don't all have that luxury.
So the person in the lower left
has nice daylight coming in.
You see coming in and it's
illuminating her face.
In other words, it's in
front of her, not behind her.
We don't actually really
know what's behind her,
but humor me here.
You have a lot of daylight coming soft,
daylight illuminating your face,
but then she also has a lamp on her desk
to help illuminate
herself a little bit more.
That would be a classic situation
where you put a daylight bulb in it.
Now people have decided
that they need more light
when they do all their Zoom meetings.
So enter the ring light.
A lot of people go out
and buy these ring lights.
They're okay unless you put it right dead
above the lens of your camera.
And then if you see the Jeff Carlson image
in the upper right hand corner,
you start seeing reflection
of the ring light
in your glasses or in your eyes,
you'll see like a little circle of light.
The best thing to do is to put
your light off to the side.
My rule of thumb in
lighting, any situation,
is that I always take the
light and move it one foot over
and one foot above the lens.
That's typically my starting point
in any kind of a lighting situation.
So if you're going to
have any extra lights,
that would probably be
a good place to start.
And then you fine tune it a
little bit as you go along.
What we will hear.
Audio is really important.
In any kind of online presentation
or any kind of a recording,
people will kinda forgive
not so good images,
but if they don't understand
the audio, you lost them,
they're gone.
So your audio has to be good quality.
It has to be clear.
The microphone, you should
have a directional microphone,
if you can, or earbuds or a headset.
Or if you're going to use
your laptop microphone,
you gotta have it closer.
You can't have it any more
than two to three feet away.
So always remember, you
have picture and sound.
An iPhone, some people when
they're doing their recordings
will use their iPhone.
Just make sure it's no more
than arms length away from you.
Set it up on a bookcase or on a tripod
or something like that,
so it's at eye level,
and make sure it's close enough.
Now Zoom does have those controls
for improving your sound.
I found that a USB microphone,
if you can find them,
actually now, they're not hard to find.
When the COVID first happened,
it was difficult to find one
of these USB microphones.
But let's go through
a little bit of a dive
a little deeper into audio.
The sound waves from your
voice or any kind of sound
hit the diaphragm inside the microphone.
It vibrates and that creates
an electrical signal.
The closer you are to the
microphone, the better,
unless you're too close
and then you'll distort it.
Most microphones have
different pickup patterns.
So you have to be aware of that.
In the bottom picture, you
have the microphone on the left
is what we call an
omnidirectional microphone.
It hears equally in all directions.
Whereas the second one, that's a cardioid,
it's a heart shape pattern,
and that picks up more directionally,
which is actually best in this situation.
Then you have other patterns,
especially in the one in the bottom right
in that blue window there.
That's a figure eight pattern.
So that's wonderful for podcasts,
when you have one microphone
for two people on it
on either side.
Now the picture on the right
gives you kind of an idea
of what we call the fall off
or the DB or decibel pattern.
You'll see that right at the
surface of the microphone,
you got 25DB,
but it doesn't take much for
it to fall off to like 5DB.
So you have a significant
loss in audio quality
by not being close
enough to the microphone.
So the way this manifests itself
is that if you have a microphone far away,
it's picking up more of the room noise,
and you're gonna sound echoy,
and it's not gonna be
that clear and distinct.
This is a closer shot of my microphone.
I use a Yeti microphone here.
You'll see that it does
have a gain control on it,
but more importantly, it has
that little pickup pattern.
That's the center image there.
You wanna make sure it's on that cardioid
or heart shaped pattern.
I know so many people get
themselves a microphone,
and then forget to set
it where it needs to be.
And then you always go
onto your Zoom Preferences
and you do your test audio
and play around with it.
So before you do your all
important recording or meeting,
test the microphone,
make sure that you don't have
the mute button pushed on it,
which I've done more than once.
See if you can get a good clean sound
where the green bar goes
about 2/3 to three quarters
of the way to the right
distance between me
and the microphone, and
you get a good sound.
Now, you're ready for
your important meeting,
'cause people really understand you.
So some audio tips.
Pay attention to your environment.
Do this when you're selecting a location
to do your recording.
So not only is it a good background,
but stop and be quiet
for a moment and listen.
Are you hearing some noises
that you can either turn off
or you can avoid?
Everything from the refrigerator
that might come on to.
I know some rooms, you hear the pipes
or you hear just the
sound of the air handlers.
So avoid situations like that.
Yeah, it is obvious, but silence
your phone and your emails
and all that other stuff,
because they will go off
right in the middle of
your best recording.
Rustling of papers, tapping on the table.
I've got my little clicker over.
You don't wanna have
it tapping on surfaces
or setting down.
But rustling papers,
especially if you're
reading from a script,
that can really be picked
up very quickly and easily.
Also consider your surfaces.
Sound waves bounce.
So in other words, if you have
a lot of large flat surfaces,
the sound waves will bounce off of that
and come back into the microphone.
Especially consider behind you.
If you have a big flat wall
behind you, guess what happens.
Your voice goes out.
It gets picked up on the
microphone, bounces off of surfaces
and comes back into microphone.
That's what gives you
that echoy muddy sound.
So always pay attention to flat surfaces.
Break it up, a couple chairs
here and there, curtains,
but also pay attention
to what's behind you.
I know that.
Believe it or not, I was
working in this industry
for many years
and we used to make these
little sound booths.
You put foam on it and you
could actually buy them,
but we used to be able to do voiceovers.
I remember talking to some
real rock and roll expert
who had done so many recordings with bands
and stuff like that.
I was saying, yeah, we
got this nice foam stuff
and it was okay,
but for some reason, the
sound still isn't great.
He says, "Guy, what's behind you?"
He says, "the wall, you idiot.
The bounce, little sound
is bouncing off the wall."
Oh, sorry.
So after that, we always put some curtains
or something behind.
It's not intuitive.
It's behind you.
But those large flat surfaces behind you
can actually be muddying your sound,
because the sound waves
are bouncing off of them
and hitting the microphone a little bit
after your voice did.
Clothing choices
White, black.
Certainly, black can be very slimming.
But remember, what we're trying to do,
we're trying to show off your face.
If you have a black shirt
on and the camera is saying,
oh gee, I don't have enough light.
Let me open up the iris,
because it's all very dark.
Well, now your face is
gonna be too bright.
So you have to pay attention
to your clothing, first of all,
as it has to be pleasant and
something that you wanna wear,
but you also wanna make sure
it's not giving you
some technical problems.
If you have a lot of white or black,
it can sometimes trick the camera's iris
into doing things that you
didn't really want it to do.
So we often recommend people
use kind of neutral clothings,
pastels, off whites,
grays, browns and blues,
that usually works best.
It's certainly easier for us
when we're lighting people,
but it'll be easier for
you to adjust the camera,
which will automatically be adjusting.
Greens are good unless
you're doing chromakey,
'cause most of the
chromakeys are green screens.
Television, computers really
don't do reds very well,
oranges or pinks.
They get confused.
They don't really, really know
how to distinguish them that well.
You can wear them, but just keep in mind
that it is going to be a
little bit more of a challenge
for the camera.
Avoid pin stripes, real thin
pin stripes or herringbone,
any kind of a close pattern.
The reason for that is
that the way the image
is being created is it's
scanning back and forth.
The electrons are scanning back and forth,
and that's how television video, whatever,
is able to create an image.
In that scanning back and forth,
thin patterns confuse the camera.
So you'll have what we
call a moire pattern.
If you have a very thin
pin striper or herringbone,
it'll look like worms are
crawling up your shirt,
which is not good.
Avoid high contrast.
You don't wanna be mixing black and white,
'cause again, you're
thinking for the camera,
and that's terrible thing is we're dealing
with technology here and
we have to think for it.
You have to anticipate
how it's gonna react.
Jewelry, yeah, that can be an issue.
But you wanna dress the
way you feel comfortable.
Just take a look at it.
That's kinda the rule
of thumb a lot of this.
Make sure you look at yourself
before you do the recording
and see if you can make an
improvement here and there.
But the bottom line is it's
setting you up to look good
and make it visible, your eyes visible.
You wanna be able to see the person,
because you're the one
that's the subject matter
and it's your presentation,
what you're saying
and how you look that's
really selling your story.
PowerPoint slides.
You're gonna have them.
Again, I understand with the 3MT,
you're gonna be alongside
of your PowerPoint.
In most of us, the Zoom puts
us in the upper hand corner,
upper right hand corner.
But you wanna make sure that
you're using wide screen.
You wanna make sure that your slides
are supporting your story,
not replacing it or distracting people.
1920 by 1080, you gotta remember
this number, 1920 by 1080,
which is wide screen,
it's the old 16 by 9.
About 10, 15 years ago,
everything went wide screen.
So the old four by three
kinda square'ish image
that we used to watch on
television, that's kinda gone.
Unfortunately, PowerPoint
still has that as a default.
So you wanna make sure
that when you're creating your slides,
you select wide screen.
It gives you more workable area too.
I find that it's better to
use a dark back background
with white or light text.
Again, I'm adverse to
having bright white sources
or light sources that are distracting,
because again, the rule thumb,
when people are looking
at any given frame,
they're gonna look at eyes first,
then they're gonna look for motion
and then they're gonna look
for the brightest spot.
So if your slide is very and
white, it's only natural,
but it's gonna be a little distracting.
Visibility resolution.
You wanna just think about how
people are seeing your image.
Are they gonna be looking at
it on a cell phone or an iPad?
Sure, everything looks great
at arms length with a laptop
or a computer.
But what will that slide look like
when it's reduced with smaller image?
Again, remember your copyright.
Do proper attribution.
You want to not be surprised down the road
that you borrowed something
that you shouldn't.
In this world of everything
online, still lives there,
people can find it and
they'll be not happy
if you just go ahead and use
their stuff without asking.
Just to help illustrate the PowerPoint.
Not every presentation you do
will always be seen at arms length.
It may be on a screen in a
room, in a conference room.
So think about how people
in the back of the room
are gonna be seeing it.
If you have a lot of white on your slide,
it's gonna be difficult for, you know.
Here, I'm talking about how
the camera would adjust for,
but also for people.
If you have a lot of white,
your eyes are like adjusting
for the room and the people,
and now the images are kinda blown out.
Whereas if you kind of
adjust to your camera
to see a slide that has a lot of white,
everything else is gonna
be a little darker.
So again, this is another plug
for putting darker slides,
darker background slides with light text.
Only natural, a lot of
logos and other images
that you have are on white.
So you can crop them and then
drop them in as appropriate.
This is in a another way,
just use your Photoshop
or any of your software to just crop it.
So now let's talk about the
3MT, three minute thesis.
Since you have a very short amount of time
to tell your story,
obviously, you have to decide
what is the need to know
from the nice to know.
This is where making that objective,
what do you want people
to really walk away with
at the end of your three minutes?
So your visuals are going
to amplify your story,
but keep in mind that if
you've got a complicated slide
or you tell people to look at the slide,
they're not gonna be hearing
your voice quite as much.
Again, we assimilate a picture
or sound, not both equally.
If you're gonna be in
the frame with the slides
and anticipate, and
again, in this situation,
you're gonna be to the left,
you're gonna be alone
the side of the image.
I find that it's better to initiate,
you make your first contact.
Remember, your first 15 seconds,
you're drawing people in.
Talk a little bit, refer to
the slide and then back to you,
so that people know when
they should look at the slide
instead of being distracted,
and then come back to you
and make sure that your
important points are being heard
with their full attention
and not kind of a distracted attention
where they're looking at the
slides and looking at you
and what do they really
want to concentrate on.
Obviously, if you can
trim out some portions
that are not needed,
but most importantly,
you wanna be dynamic.
You wanna bring that story to
life and give yourself time,
so that you're not rushing it.
Maybe that should be a two and
a half minute thesis planned
to fill in for three minutes.
So here's a few examples.
If you notice the framing,
the way you're gonna be
recording this is on Panopto,
so that's gonna put you along the side.
Unfortunately, it's gonna
leave a lot of dead space
in the top and bottom,
which is all the more reason
why you wanna make sure
that your slide is not too cluttered.
In this situation, it
was very dynamic speaker.
He framed himself such that
you could see his hands
and that's okay if
you're gonna be dynamic.
The background is a little
plain, it's not bad,
but when you have a
background that simple,
you gotta make sure you have
enough light on your face,
because you're gonna
have reflected light too.
But this fellow had broke his
slides into logical patterns.
So he talked, he referred to
the first part of his slide,
then back to him and then to the middle
and then to the latter part.
So he kinda broke his slides
up into a logical fashion,
and then his presentation
referred to it and then back.
It was very successful.
This person did a very similar type thing.
You noticed that her
framing is much closer,
much easier to see her eyes.
She wasn't one that was
gesturing that much,
but her slides also were
very logically laid out.
It was easy for the eye
to follow those things
and then come back to her,
and not be stuck on the slide
trying to figure it out.
It was uncluttered,
which it was really nice.
This image, okay, I'm
gonna kinda toss it to you.
What do you think about this?
Right.
His camera level is a little low.
So we're seeing a ceiling.
The background is a little
clutter, but not bad.
I don't think this one really is that bad,
but I think the most important thing
is to get the camera at eye level.
You wanna do that.
He still would've been fairly well lit,
but seeing the light fixture up above him
is gonna confuse the camera.
So I think if he had gotten
himself at eye level,
everything else kind of
would've taken care of itself.
But it also gives you,
is this a situation
where you would wanna use
one of those virtual backgrounds
or the soft focus ones?
I think those are fine.
It keeps you from being
distracted by the background.
The only thing that
you get to keep in mind
in using the virtual backgrounds
is to make sure it's a clean,
what we call a clean mask.
In other words, you don't
see any residual image.
As the person, you have to move your head.
You've probably seen it if
you used a virtual background.
When you move a little
bit, sometimes the camera,
the technology doesn't continue
making a nice clean image around you.
It's kind of a like soft and
sometimes you'll actually see
a little bit of the background.
So try things out, in a
circumstance like this,
You could argue that aside
from getting at eye level,
you could argue that maybe the background
is a little too busy
and you wanna go with the
soft focus virtual background,
or you could just go with what it is.
He's slides, again,
you're actually looking
at the eyes of the zebra
for a second there too.
So make sure your slides
are easily visible.
You're not wasting any space,
because in a situation like this,
your slide is only about 1/3
of the usable entire screen.
So playing accordingly.
Going back to images and legal
issues and stuff like that.
Since I do have a JED, I have
to think about these things.
You wanna be careful of your copyright
and make sure you get
permissions and all that stuff.
In the old saying,
if you do it right,
you can sleep at night.
When I upload videos to
the Yale YouTube channel,
I am continuously amazed
that within a minute,
sometimes seconds,
I will know whether
there was a legal issue
and there's a copyright issue.
Usually, with music.
Sometimes I'll get the
material and we edit it
and we put it up, and we don't
realize that the presenter
had something in it.
But on YouTube and any
of these online things,
they were able to pick up misused images
and certainly misused sound.
So you wanna be careful.
It's as simple as sending
an email to the person
that you're using their images
and just ask permission.
Speaker permission forms.
The rule of thumb is that if
you're using somebody's name
in likeness, they need to give permission.
So you may have been asked
to sign a release form
for your 3MTs,
or any other time that
you're using a guest speaker.
Alternatively, in some
cases, you can put a notice
at the beginning that says
the event is being recorded
and it gives you an option out.
Or when you option in, you
know that you're being recorded
and it maybe become public.
Yes, your presentation
may be seen on YouTube.
All of you, if that's one
of the places that material
that we you do goes.
The Yale Office of General
Counsel has a website.
They do have some legal
information and some guidance,
and they have something
called a Fair Use tool.
If you have questions about
whether what you're using
fulfills the exclusion
from copyright for what's called fair use,
they have a tool and you
could just look at it.
Basically, fair use is a
four point balancing test
where you're looking at
different elements of the image
and balancing it to see
whether it tips the balance
to, yeah, that's fair
use, go ahead and use it,
to that's not really fair use,
you're probably gonna get in trouble.
So that's one thing to consider.
Bottom line, you're gonna
successfully communicate
your story on this, right?
When you're online,
you're telling a story.
Keep in mind that people can
assimilate the spoken word
or your images, but not
necessarily at the same time,
certainly not equally at the same time.
The video resolution is important.
Many people do look at things
on cellphones or iPads.
Just keep in mind.
I told you to remember the 1920 by 1080,
that's your full resolution
for high definition.
It may be squeezed down to 1280 by 720,
and it's still your 16 by 9 aspect ratio.
But if things get squeezed down,
is your slide gonna be so
detailed that we don't see it,
or it's gonna be so detailed that people
are spending their time
trying to figure it out
and they're not paying attention to you.
So again, that's a plug for making sure
that your slides are not cluttered.
Remember about the slides
is they should be supporting
your important spoken points.
Your spoken word is
going to carry the day.
That's gonna decide
whether you are successful
in communicating your story or not.
The slides will help,
but it's your spoken word
that's going to make the difference.
If you're on a slide,
your voice is reinforcing the visuals.
In other words, if you've
called people's attention
to the slide and you want
them to be looking at it,
keep in mind that they're
gonna now be focused on that
and they're gonna be reading it,
and your voice is not so important.
So that's not the time
when you make your most important point.
You wanna get people back to you
and then you can make your point.
But above all, you're telling a story
with your voice and your visuals.
Hopefully, that helped you
get your online presentation
in your staging in order.
Don't forget the evaluation form.
So we can stop the screen sharing
and maybe we can get onto
some of these questions.
- [Julia] Thank you so much, Guys.
So virtual hand claps,
I'm sure from everybody.
I was tracking some excellent questions.
So I think I'll just throw them your way.
I'll keep my camera off.
Does that sound like a good?
- (laughs) Sure.
- [Julia] So before we move
on to the first question,
can people reach out to you, Guy,
if they have questions about
their own presentations
or logistical questions?
Is that all right?
- Yes, yes.
- [Julia] Okay, I know
you're very responsive
on email as well.
Wonderful.
So my first question is from Linda.
This is a bit earlier in the presentation.
Linda wrote, "my Zoom
puts the speaker directly
to the right of the slides
centered on the vertical access,
dot dot dot, is that a setting?"
- That's fine.
Yeah, that is a setting.
There is a side-by-side
view or the upper view.
I think in the recording,
it will always put it in
the upper right hand corner.
But in the actual, what you see
at the time you're doing it,
it's along the side.
I frankly prefer it along
the side, if you ask me,
because when it's in the
upper right hand corner,
it sometimes obscures
part of your PowerPoint.
- [Julia] Wonderful.
Carson asks, "would you
recommend that we either use
an image background or
a blurred background?
My only real life background options
are white walls or bookshelves."
- You can try with the image.
Again, one suggestion is
to try and and soften it,
so it's not so sharp.
Like for example, I had
behind me a picture I took
when we were out hiking
and I looked at it,
I says, well, it looks
really, really nice,
but it's too nice.
It's gonna be distracting.
So I did made it soft
focused a little bit,
so it's not as prominent.
I kinda like the soft focus background
on these virtual backgrounds.
As long as it's not seen
a bright light behind you,
that can be a pretty good choice.
Or again, if you've got an image
that you're comfortable with
and it's not distracting,
and I think that's kind of
the guiding principle there,
is it distracting and
drawing the attention away
from the viewer that you don't wanna do.
- [Julia] Yeah, and Carson's
right there with his image.
So maybe you can look at it right now,
'cause there's slightly blurred.
But actually, in the a
six paint panel example
that you were giving about
like good and bad ways
to kind of put yourself
in front of the lens,
there is a bookshelf and the good one
and the good image with the warmer walls,
but it's not as busy of a bookshelf.
It's not-
- It's not a focus.
It's not a focus.
I think that's the key thing.
It's far enough back
that you can't really pick
out individual images,
because believe it or
not, people get bored
and they start looking around in an image
for something else to look at.
If you give it to them,
they'll look at it.
So I think in that image with
Jeff Carlson, if you recall,
the book case in the
background was a little softer
and not a focus.
- [Julia] Interesting.
So as long as they can't read the spine,
then you're fine.
- Yeah, I think so.
I just look at it yourself.
Are you distracted by it?
Is there something in there
that's really drawing
your eye away from it?
Well, then it's not so good.
Find another background.
- [Julia] Okay, thank you.
So Arita asks, "would you suggest
any simple post-processing
steps for the 3MT videos?"
- In the past, we actually
used to edit those.
We did them when we were
recording them in a auditorium.
Right now, I don't know
what to say on that.
You're being recorded on Panopto.
I don't know whether what
options you may have on that.
I just don't know.
That would probably be the
question for the administrator
for the 3MT, as to whether
other options you have.
- [Julia] From working
with Panopto in the past,
because we've uploaded fellowship panels
and things like that, it's
very easy to use the clip.
You can clip it very easily.
It's right there, it's
like little scissors,
like literally there to
clip the keep a video.
So what you could do is play.
I would suggest playing around first,
record some willy-nilly
things that doesn't matter,
upload it, and then see what
features you'd like to have.
In that way, it'll give
you some abilities,
if you wanted to clip or.
- Yeah, and I think along that same line,
that might be a good time for
you to try out your slide.
Is this something that is
cluttered and difficult to read
when it's now on the smaller screen?
So that might be a good way.
If you can do a test
recording with your slide
and then look at it.
Look at your recording afterwards,
can you clearly see the
slide and you or not?
And then you make adjustments accordingly.
- Melissa asks, "will
other mobile phones work
for sound or just iPhone?"
- Well, as a proud owner
of an iPhone, I don't know.
(Guy laughing)
I'm assuming so.
I mean, I gotta believe that
other iPhones have microphones
on them, so it should.
You do a test recording.
I mean, try it.
Just remember, it's the
proximity to the microphone
that makes a huge difference.
If the camera on your
phone and the microphone
is more than arms length,
I think you're gonna start
having some fall off.
But I would just try it.
- [Julia] So then Linda asked
a question about copyright.
In their experience, live
academic conferences,
like classroom teaching have
different copyright terms,
but it sounds like since
this is being recorded,
is it just a given that it will be treated
like a public recording
or specifically for 3MT
and then in brackets?
I mean, does this more strict
sense of fair use copyright
apply to all recordings for Yale purposes
or specifically to this competition?
- That's a good question.
I do recall that the 3MTs
do end up on YouTube.
I think I recall that.
I think it's a good practice period.
Just borrowing stuff
because it's available
is not a good way to live
your life. (chuckles)
The classroom exclusion is kind of narrow.
So in other words, I
think if you were to go
to the Office of General Counsel
and take a look at their
fair use analysis tool,
you'll see that there's
a narrow band there
on what is still considered
fair use in classroom.
So without giving any legal advice,
I think the bottom line is try
and get permission to these things,
or certainly put the
attribution at the bottom.
So in other words, it
doesn't take too much,
when you're putting together your slide,
to put an attribution
of where you got it from
at the bottom in small text.
- Well, those are the only
questions that I got in the chat.
So I'd like to leave open some room
if anyone else wants
to ask a question live.
You can raise your hand
and kind of unmute yourself
and just throw it out there.
While people are thinking,
Guy, is it something that would
be appropriate to maybe ask
for like a schedule a meeting with you?
If you're a 3MT contestant
to kinda work the slides,
kinda get your feedback.
What are the parameters do you think
for something like that?
- Send me an email.
- Okay.
- There at guy.orotleva@yale.edu.
Send me an email and
we'll see what we can do.
I'm sure that people
are not gonna be breaking
down my doors. (laughs)
So I'm sure we can find
some time to help you.
- That's great.
I mean, yeah, it's really
just about what you're willing
to put into it, but just
from working with Guy,
clearly, he's very knowledgeable.
So if that's a resource that
you have time to consider,
I would highly suggest that,
and it counts for the
certificate program too
as a consultation.
- Oh, boy.
- Yeah.
Guy, thank you so much.
As always, this is amazing, super helpful.
I wish I had known this a long time ago,
but this is why we do the work that we do
to bring these resources to all of you,
so you can go off and
conquer and do amazing work
that you do and share it with the world.
So thank you so much, Guy.
More to come, I'm sure,
this was really wonderful.
Thank you everyone for
participating and attending
and let's give like a
virtual round of applause.